I said, "Mom, I got news for you."
And she said, "Well before your news, go get some milk."
I said, "It's 10 o'clock in the night. Why should I get milk?"
And I noticed that my husband's car was in the garage.
I said, "Why don't you tell him to get the milk."
She said, "Well, he came at 8:00."
"He was very tired..."
"...so I let him be."
"Now you go get the milk."
And you know, you never question your mom...
...so I went and got the milk,...
...came back, sort of banged it on the countertop and I said,...
"I had big news for you."
"I'd just been appointed president of PepsiCo..."
"...and all that you care about is the milk."
She just looked at me and she said,..
"What are you talking about?"
She said, "When you walk in that door, just leave that crown in the garage..."
"...because you are the wife, the daughter,..."
"...the daughter-in-law and the mother of the kids."
"And that's all I want to talk about."